اكد مؤسس فاجنر ان القوات الروسيه حصلت
عمليا مدينه بالكامل لافتان الى امتلاك
القوات الاوكرانيه لطريق خروج واحد من
المدينه وفق تعبيره وداعا الرئيس
الاوكراني
الى سحب قوته من المدينه التي تعد الجبهه
الاكثر اشتعالا منذ اشهر
من دونيات مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر رائد
اهلا بك معنا ابرز التطورات اليوم
جيش الروسي او قوات فاجنر اختراقها وهي في
المنطقه الغربيه اذا استطاع الجيش الروسي
اختراق مدينه خروجما فهذا يعني بانه اكمل
الطوق حيث الطريق السريع الى مدينه
شاسوفيا المدينه التي وصفها ايضا بريغوجين
بانها الطريق الوحيد لانسحاب القوات
الاوكرانيه بالفعل تقدمت قوات من المحور
الشمالي في عده شوارع وعده احياء وايضا من
المنطقه الشرقيه وصلت الى اطراف منتصف
المدينه قلب المدينه حتى الان لم تسيطر
على الحي الذي يعني يكون في منتصف المدينه
حيث ما زالت هنا قوات اوكرانيه تدافع وما
زالت الامدادات تصل للجيش الاوكراني في
قلب المدينه كما ان المحور الجنوبي من
المدينه ايضا سيطرت على اجزاء كبيره منه
عده كيلومترات قوات فاجنر تسيطر على احياء
سكنيه في
مجمع سباشكا وايضا في احياء قريبه من
الوسط يعني عمليا القلب المدينه مطوق من
القوات الروسيه قوات فاجنر واطراف المدينه
من الاعلى كلها مطوقه عدا المحور الغربي
من قلب المدينه الى الناحيه الغربيه كله
مفتوح